next week a new League of Legends story
will begin convergence A League of
Legends story is a new game that follows
one of League's most loved characters
reimagined in a most incredible way I
got to play the game and talk to the
team behind it to find out why League
fans should be excited
[Music]
alright before we get into the video you
might have noticed that my background
has changed us because I'm in London
right now covering MSI we've got a whole
bunch of content to show you guys so if
that sounds like your cup of tea then
make sure you like the video and you'll
subscribe to the channel for all the
future content
[Music]
[Applause]
at its heart convergence is a story
about Echo and the City of Zorn Echo has
been in League now for eight years and
the boy who shattered time has been a
crowd favorite ever since both on and
off the rift his popularity reached new
levels when he featured in the Netflix
show Arcane we learned a lot about his
backstory as the childhood friend of Vai
and Jinx and member of the fire lights
as they sabotage silco's plans in Zorn
and now convergence will cover another
chapter in echo's story
foreign
it's a story driven single-player 2D
platformer with gameplay built around
echo's ability to manipulate time it's
made by double stallion a Montreal based
studio in collaboration with Riot Forge
and it's pretty dope starting in
the some sewers convergence follows Echo
as he hacks slashes and slides through
Zorn the polluted undercity Below
pilsover in runeterra the fictional
World in which League of Legends is set
he's tasked by his future self no less
with saving his underworld home from a
looming danger battling familiar faces
from League's cast including Camille and
Warwick and we'll even get the chance to
see Jinx in this game which will be
exciting for fans who want to see more
of her Torrid relationship with Echo
although the game sees Echo jumping
hacking and slashing his way through
levels in the usual platformer style
convergence takes things to a whole new
dimension because Echo has time on his
side echo's rewind ability he makes him
jump back in time for a few seconds
which allows the player to learn from
their mistakes and tackle a challenge
multiple times if needed and this was
something I particularly enjoyed when I
got the chance to play the demo because
yeah I was making a lot of mistakes his
parallel convergence ability slows down
time in an area which is useful for
dealing with fast-moving enemies and
projectiles and if you recognize the
name of that ability from League well
that's because although he may be echoed
by name in this game he may be echoed by
a slightly different nature than League
fans will be used to and this is
something that the game's creative and
co-art director Eric angelilo talked to
me about in more detail the most
exciting thing to me when I think of
myself as a fan of echo which I am as
well is that we were because it's a
single player narrative driven game we
were really able to recreate time rewind
in a way that you could never do in a
PVP game like League of Legends which
would be totally unfair right uh so but
in this game you can you know anytime
you sort of have a slip up or you make a
mistake or even if you didn't make a
mistake but you kind of want to take it
again because you feel like there's a
different approach you can take you can
kind of rewind a few seconds and try it
again and and do it even better but time
isn't the only tool at echo's disposal
there's his phase dive which teleports
him to his Target for a slash attack he
can Parry projectiles use spin attacks
and fire off his iconic time Winder as a
range attack as the game progresses Echo
can use workbenches with rare parts to
create gadgets that upgrade his
abilities this customization allows
players to tweak Echo to the playstyle
they enjoy most and the game is also
just very pretty to look at in between
the moments of high octane Mayhem there
are intervals where you can really just
catch your breath and appreciate how
visually enthralling the game is like
when fireflies guided me through the
darkness because for me the vibrant art
style shines through just as strongly in
convergence as its innovative gameplay
with the art Direction in particular we
really want to like push this kind of
like his his sort of world view Echoes
the champion who's young he's very kind
of optimistic heroic uh and so he sees
on as more than just this kind of
polluted Metropolis but really has this
vibrant City uh and we try to reflect
this in the colors and the neon accents
and all that the whole experience really
does feel like you're leaping through
the panels of a comic book when I first
heard that the game was set in the dark
underbelly that is Zorn I was a bit
concerned that the game could look drab
and a bit Bleak but everywhere you turn
the game just pulses with brilliant RGB
color and layers of 2D backgrounds with
vibrant palettes that stay true to the
game's grimy setting as I mentioned
earlier convergence is just the latest
collaboration between Riot Forge and a
third-party developer to create spin-off
games that are set in the League of
Legends Universe this division of Riot
has already produced the likes of Ruin
King and hextech Mayhem with other
titles such as song of nunu and Mage
Seeker coming soon and I have to say
it's incredibly exciting thing to
finally see the riot Forge train picking
up some speed Riot games being a plural
name used to feel like a bit of a meme
back in the early days of League of
Legends but with the release of these
titles that seems like a distant memory
or memory now the cold cynical view here
might be the riot is simply flexing its
corporate muscle to break into every
niche of the gaming industry but to me
this is allowing Gamers of every
persuasion no matter what genre of game
they like to get a taste of the League
of Legends universe that has captivated
people for a decade now and from my talk
with the folks over at Double stallion
it seems like their collaboration was
definitely a positive one I think
working with Ford was just like a huge
uh learning experience so just working
with such a great like huge IP as League
of Legends which is really cool and we
work really closely with Forge to kind
of like build the game out and sort of
like connect with the lore uh in a way
that you know the stuff we learn and and
from that experience we can apply to our
own IP in the future and the games we're
working on now convergence A League of
Legends story will be released on all
platforms on May 23rd and I have one
question for you will you be playing it
perhaps you've already played some other
Rio Ford games and this is already on
your radar I have to admit that as
someone who's only ever really played
league and a little bit of TFT I am
genuinely excited to play this sometimes
I get so wrapped up in the Esports side
of this world that I forget about the
rich world that Riot has been weaving
here for over a decade this might be the
excuse to jump back into it
I used to play so much of echo back in
the day specifically tank Echo so you
did no damage but you're the most
irritating champion in the game at that
point it was horribly oppressive I would
have I would never wish to play against
it but uh I think it got me to platinum
10K So yeah thank you Echo big fan